tourism is the horse that pulls the cart
Egypt's Minister of Tourism was recently
quoted as saying dozens of industries
depend on foreign travelers hotels and
restaurants to construction food
production and souvenir shops but these
days sellers in Egypt's bazaars have
little else to do than dust off their
wares the situation in general in Egypt
isn't stable so tourists won't come
during an unstable time for tourism or
even for the economy with regards to
tourism it's now a very bad time tourism
is decreasing that just aren't any
tourists Egypt's economy has struggled
since the 2011 revolution and now it
faces new uncertainty the European Union
and the u.s. had committed to giving
Egypt 5 billion and 1 billion euros
respectively in military and economic
aid now those promises are under review
Arab countries say they'll make up for
any aid cuts from the West Saudi Arabia
has already promised 3.8 billion euros
Kuwait and the United Arab Emirates also
planned contributions but direct aid to
the Egyptian state will do little to
resolve the fundamental problem as long
as the unrest and political divisions
continue the economic outlook for the
Arab world's most populous country
remains bleak